have you ever heard that on a given day
there were more sellers than buyers on
the stock market this is especially
common during recessions when people are
dumping billions of dollars of stock
like warren buffett recently did with
this four billion dollar airline
portfolio but at the same time we know
that each stocks hill needs a buyer for
the transaction to go through so in such
scenarios who is buying all of this
stock
[Music]
well first of all when people or the
media see that there were more sellers
and buyers on the market this means that
there were more sellers than buyers at
the opening of the market not the entire
day so as the stock price drops the pool
of sellers and buyers is likely to
equalize and if it doesn't then the
stock price continues to drop until this
statement becomes more or less true but
oftentimes in recessions it seems like
everyone you know is selling and that no
one is willing to buy while it may seem
like this from personal experience this
is basically never true at least not for
blue chip stocks or big company stocks
for instance let's take Apple their
average stock volume is about 50 million
this means that on average 50 million
shares are being traded every single day
the vast majority of any stock shares
are traded during market hours which is
usually only six to seven hours around
the world but to estimate conservatively
we'll say that Apple stock is traded at
the same rate during pre market and
after hours Nasdaq which is a platform
on which Apple stock is traded is open
from 4:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. if you add
in pre market and aftermarket hours so
on any weekday you have 16 hours to
trade Apple stock given a daily volume
of 50 million shares
this means that 868 shares of Apple
stock is being traded every single
second or 270 thousand dollars worth
this comes out to 52,000 shares or 16
million dollars worth of stock every
single minute and that's conservative as
you can see even if you are trying to
buy or sell millions of dollars worth of
stock this can be done in a matter of
minutes you might be saying apples
aren't the world's biggest companies so
the same volume cannot be expected for
smaller companies but this again is not
true Delta for instance only has a
valuation that is nearly 1% of apples
valuation however it's a free volume is
still 46 million the thing is there are
hundreds of mutual funds hedge funds and
brokers themselves buying and selling
that volume every single day
so with these behemoths selling and
buying mad volumes individual investors
can pretty much always find a buyer or a
seller despite how the mark is
performing overall that's 90 percent of
stocks these stocks might go down for a
couple of months or years but it's
expected that over long periods of time
they are still on an upward trend
keeping buyers interested but there are
also companies that go bankrupt and
completely stop operation during a
recession so who is buying the shares of
companies with terrible outlooks well in
many cases it could be the company
itself sure you and your friends as well
as all institution bachelors may not
believe in the company but the company
may still believe in the company this
was the case with Adele in the early
2010's investor confidence was
plummeting as profits in revenue tumbled
in 2012 and a majority of investors were
looking to sell to avoid pressure from
investors and a bad public image
Michael Adele came in and essentially
bought every last stock out there given
the situation sixty five percent of his
investors were ready sell doll stock and
voted in favor of a buyout and so
Michael Dell was able to buy back all of
Dell shares for twenty five billion
dollars or thirteen point seven five
dollars per share
luckily for Dell mr. Dell was able to
turn everything around and returned to
the market in the 40s for share in 2018
but even if Adele had gone bankrupt the
investors were able to cash out before
the bankruptcy and this is the same
scenario with many companies with bad
outlooks the companies themselves are
who are buying shares when everyone is
selling but at the same time many of
them don't have a cash or can't take our
debt to buy back shares so in cases
where bankruptcy is inevitable what
happens to shareholders well this
depends on what type of bankruptcy were
talking about the two main types are
chapter 11 and 7 in a chapter 11
bankruptcy the companies basically
postponing financial obligations in
order to buy some time to hopefully
recover in the meantime shareholders can
usually not sell
and in stock as there are literally no
buyers available however if the company
recovers like Delta American Airlines
converse Six Flags Marvel or General
Motors who have all felt for chapter 11
bankruptcy in the past shareholders will
eventually regained ability to sell
shares in fact in such recoveries there
will often be more buyers than sellers
and I'm not sure if you would even want
to sell but in a chapter 7 bankruptcy
your stock is nearly meaningless as a
company shutting down generally the
company's assets will be sold and then
the debt will be paid off if there is
still any cash left over shareholders
will be paid back in accordance to their
ownership but generally shareholders get
no return in chapter 7 bankruptcy
finally there is one more scenario non
blue chip stocks or very small company
stocks these stocks are generally penny
stocks or stocks worth under $5 these
companies may have very small volume and
in such scenarios is actually possible
for there to be no buyers even when the
company is performing as expected but
even for these companies there are
always buyers but there may be no buyers
at your desired price and in such cases
the only solution is to wait until a
buyer pops up which could be a matter of
days or even weeks or reduce your asking
price so in general for blue chip stocks
no matter how the economy is doing or
how many people are selling there'll
always be buyers just because of the raw
number of people and institutions
interested in the company for companies
with a bad outlook however the buyer
could be the company itself the only
time you'll have trouble finding a buyer
is for companies that are bankrupt or
very close to it as well as non blue
chip stocks so if you're only investing
in solid blue chip stocks you'll never
run at their problem of liquidity if you
guys thought this video explained
liquidity concerns in the stock market
well then make sure drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Ari na see you guys on the next
one
you